oh hey look
a Planned Parenthood yeah no
that's a fake Planned Parenthood
what are you talking about
it says plan choices and women use all those words on purpose
they use all those words on purpose to lure unsuspecting women
into thinking that they're gonna be offered all the choices
but they're just gonna be convinced not to get an ab0rs!on
okay well
if they don't offer ab0rs!on
then why does their website literally say that they do
because they're lying
most of these fake clinics don't even have a single doctor on staff
to perform the medical services that they say that they do
that's bad okay
well I guess performing ultrasounds on pregnant women can't hurt
yeah if the staff had medical licenses
that they don't and so they're performing ultrasounds on pregnant women
and could miss serious conditions
like ectopic pregnancies that's bad
okay well
at least they can't harm women who already had ab0rs!on right
no they tell those women that they can reverse their ab0rs!on can you
yep
that's common sense up here
but you don't know that
this clinic essentially telling women that they can reverse their abortion
so literally their pin post on Facebook
I fear Okey dokey
okay so our elected officials must be doing something about this right
well a bunch of them have actually already passed laws
that force doctors to say that abortions can be reversed
my god I'm itchy everywhere
oh I know
okay there's a presidential election coming up
what can we do
when Kamala Harris was age of California
she actually mandated these fake clinics to stop lying to women
okay okay
and then what about uh
Donald Trump and JD Dance
they don't really have a plan about how to protect women
okay so they don't have a plan to protect women from the fake clinics
but it's not like they have a plan
to make it harder for women to access the real ones right
uh
you know I gotta go
wait didn't Donald Trump probably pay for ab0rs!ions
probably he's just doesn’t want you to